the battlefield sandbox has its share of
busted weapons over the years
some were quickly fixed and others just
became meme worthy
what's up all i'm david and i got a fun
quick list for you today
now most of my experience personally
lately has been with battlefield 1
but will definitely include infamous
guns from across the series
if you want to see more battlefield
stuff leave a like and if you're
really ready for some battlefield 6 news
then absolutely hit that subscribe and
bell button
it's free let's get started
everyone hates getting one shot but if
you were a fan of not just getting easy
one hit kos
but even bringing up some wicked
collateral kills as well
then you are most likely familiar with
the first entry on our list
the martini henry infantry rifle used by
the scout class
oh [ __ ] boys
the gun has been nerfed currently to
where the only real advantage is it's
one hit ko range compared to other
rifles in the same class
but pre-patch the martini henry had a
monstrous one-hit ko window
for shots to lay down on torsos and even
arms and legs
usually to get the full 100 damage in
order to kill you'd need a headshot
but to be able to wipe out squats by
just shooting them in the gut between 30
to 80 meters is definitely op territory
to unlock the gun you had some initial
grinding to do if you don't normally
play the scout class
as the rifle only unlocks once you reach
scout class level 10.
there's still plenty of players that
favor the rifle from its slick sound
design to its aesthetic
but all that is honestly wasted on me
then again i found myself unfortunately
on the receiving end of the martini
henry infantry rifle
multiple times here we get into the m16
where battlefield 3 veterans who have
played the game longer than i have will
most likely shudder at the idea of this
gun
and the hands of a player like me that
is to say any low-level players seem to
be able to suddenly turn
god tier with an assault rifle that had
exceptional stats across the board
from its rate of fire inaccuracy even
from the hip
to its versatility in combat at almost
any range
the gun was a force to be reckoned with
before it eventually got patched
keep in mind battlefield is a game of
opportunity cost when you use a certain
class
you're expecting certain advantages at
the expense of others
but with the m16a3 you didn't have to
sacrifice anything
which naturally caused problems for
everyone who wasn't currently using the
rifle
[Music]
battlefield 3 has another entry on this
list with absolute overpowered and
busted weaponry
this time in the form of a 12 gauge
shotgun the usa s12
with frag rounds now a great way to get
a gun straight onto everyone's [ __ ] list
is its ease of use everyone and i mean
everyone of all skill types can grab
this thing hold down the fire button
and go to town thanks to its ridiculous
combination of damage
range and fire rate
the gun has inspired countless forms of
debate and even various parodies and
memes
and it destroys the line between kind of
feeling rewarding and arcady
which isn't a bad thing it's kind of
hilarious
and this was after the gun was already
patched so i can't even imagine how it
must have felt
in game at the time but do any basic
search online and you'll see gameplay
clips of just how broken and busted this
gun was
especially against vehicles
there's something to be said about a
weapon being broken partly because
everyone in the game decides that they
need to use it what i'm saying here is
that in battlefield 1
the hell regal 1915 factory smg was a
weapon that was very forgiving
but was quickly viewed as busted and
overpowered almost through a weird case
of community peer pressure
now if you're dying to an enemy using
the smg that's fine right
now imagine a dozen assault class
enemies are all using the hell regal
the probability of your streaks coming
to an end the hands of this smg
dramatically increases which is what
every battlefield 1 player experienced
the smg wasn't easy to access either at
first it was one of the final weapons
assault class players unlocked
and it even has some weaknesses such as
sporting a below average damage per
round stat
but thanks to its incredibly high
magazine tight spread
and incredible versatility the appeal of
this highly goal for all types of
players
became unavoidable and it's a big reason
why this gun is viewed as unbalanced
the more popular it became battlefield's
most recent title threw some love to the
medic class with an incredibly popular
smg
surprise surprise that encouraged a type
of playstyle that irritated a lot of
players
simply because of how forgiving and
busted the gun turned out to be with an
incredibly fast fire rate of over a
thousand rpm
with a potential upgrade of going even
beyond that to 1200 rpm
the common trade-off would be a small
magazine and needing to constantly
reload
however the nambu type 2a not only had a
fairly hefty magazine clip
but also had an incredibly quick reload
speed combine that with the one class
that could heal themselves faster
and you ended up facing some of the most
aggressive medics the franchise ever saw
so that's our quick list for this run
but if you felt like you've been
egregiously wronged by a particularly
broken weapon
that wasn't on this list just yet let us
know in the comments and discuss which
guns were totally busted and you never
know
you might find your nightmare gun on a
part 2 list in the future
thanks for watching
do
[Music]
do